there steve kaufman here today i want to
tell you
the secret of how i learn languages
that's the subject of my discussion
today
people often say to me
you know steve you've obviously got a
talent for languages
you've learned so many languages you
know good for you but i could never do
it and i often say to myself at least
well why don't you try doing it the way
i do it
maybe
it's also a matter of the method that i
use
and so i want to tell you exactly now
because it's really quite simple
the secret to how i learn languages to
me
learning languages is is essentially the
i would summarize it this way it's the
relentless pursuit of words
words that i glean
through content that is of interest to
me
that's basically what it boils down to
uh if i look at the languages that i
have learned french in a way doesn't
count because i had it at school and
then i studied it at mcgill and then i
went to france where i studied
in french at the institute politik and
so i was you know eventually was
immersed in it as i say in my book i
really couldn't speak much in french but
once i got turned down to french it
wasn't difficult in montreal and
subsequently in france to achieve quite
a high level the significance with
french is that it made me confident that
i could learn but in chinese i remember
when i was in hong kong i would scour
the bookstores
looking for material that had these
glossaries like readers
um readers on chinese literature
politics history anything i could find
any book that anybody put out that had
some kind of content with a glossary so
i wouldn't have to use the dictionary i
would buy them and and that i didn't
just use the textbook that they had at
my chinese language school and so i was
on chinese for nine months and and
that's but essentially i between that
and listening a lot that's how i learned
and and i as i have said many times i
ignored the grammatical explanations and
just got used to the patterns
in japanese i had to learn it on my own
and there again i would just scour the
bookstores for as much material as i
could find
so this whole idea that that language
learning is a matter of pursuing words
okay it's it's just that's very simple
and that's what we have put into link
and i get kind of annoyed sometimes
that you know at link i'm one of the
most
prolific linkers like i do more saving
of words and phrases than most people
uh i'm very disappointed in this because
to me
the fastest way to learn is to create a
lot of links to do a lot of reading
and then while reading to just
link words at random i mean i've been at
czech for
two months not quite two months and i've
created over 10 000 links
when i sit down to read some things
especially at my level in check if i go
to a newspaper there's a lot of words
that i don't know i'm just creating
links and i don't worry about whether i
remember the meaning
just to explain when i create a link i
have the dictionary the
dictionary definition comes up i save it
to my database
and
i'll just collect them by the thousands
and
when i read again i see them highlighted
in yellow it reminds me that i i looked
them up but by no means do i know those
words so that linking is just
a way of making much more automatic
what was my essential learning process
and that is acquiring words
and yet people are reluctant to do that
if they say 10 20 words they think they
have to learn them memorize them make
sure they know them
do i really know this word is it my
passive only vocabulary how do i make it
active
you know is it masculine feminine what
case is it i don't worry about that i
just pile the words up
and then every so often i go through
them as i'm doing now in check
and i'm looking at them carefully and
i'm tagging them which is something we
can do in link so i'm tagging them for
case because i want to become a little
more
uh attentive you know as i've said
before language learning is attitude
time with the language and attentiveness
so i have to become a little more
attentive to what's happening so i'm
going to focus on case for a while and
so because i'm
quite
you know
having a clue what the different case
endings in in check are which e
and which ones they are and and so forth
it's different from russian obviously
and so i'll do a bit of that and that
helps me become attentive and then i
just go right back to creating links
and and to me the way we design link is
we like to keep track of how many links
have you created how many words do you
know the way we count them and here
again people get so uptight you know if
i
because one of our learners was doing
korean and he was surprised that i had
saved so many links in czech and he
hadn't saved as many in korean and even
though he had studied korean longer so i
went in and did a lesson in korean and
in an hour i saved 160
links or so
uh just to to demonstrate that if i'm
going to go at it i'm going to save
links now the words that you don't save
those are considered known
so it's very possible that in the
so-called known words there are words
that you skipped over words that you
don't really know
names and all kinds of stuff it doesn't
matter it's a measurement of your
progress it doesn't mean like according
to my statistics that link i know 13 000
check words i don't know 13 000 czech
words however
i can just i can make my way through the
newspaper i've been at it for two months
and the vocabulary is quite different
from russian
and so i feel that i'm making
because link is so much more efficient
now than than it was when i started with
russian i mean i'm making so much faster
progress now than i was making before
but the key element is that that the
what you have to do in line with
learning in my opinion is you have to go
after words
words that you acquire through reading
occasionally you review them i don't
because i only have
an hour an hour and a half a day i can't
spend three hours with my anki
uh flash guard deck
you know if i got 10 000 words
so i prefer to review these in a
sporadic fashion tagging them for cases
and then i want to get right back again
to reading
creating links and then listening
because once i've finished my work at
the computer then i've got something
that i can listen to in the car wherever
i am but the fundamental point is that
and and you know i'm reluctant sometimes
to stress this because you know
everybody says well i got my own way and
people feel very strongly about their
own way of language learning and you
know fine they have every right to to do
that
uh i mean we have you know some people
think that that you can talk your way to
fluency in three months well i don't
believe that
uh but some people are happy
at least trying to do that
and if you're happy with the process
then it's good because again
i do believe that it's attitude
it's time with the language and and it's
attentiveness that matter
but
sometimes i think you know maybe i'm not
the least successful language learner so
maybe some people might listen
to what i do
and not just say oh well you're good at
it
i'm going to go back to this other way
that doesn't work
because i'm no good
well maybe you're not very effective
because the method you're using isn't
very effective
and maybe i sometimes think at link we
should set the target for linking much
much higher than we do
much much higher and try and sort of
promote the ideas go and massively
link
multi-link you know
anyway i just felt that i should say
that because i i
i don't want to force my way on others
although i do
you know
because i really think it works and i
think language learning is actually
quite simple it's a bit like as i often
say
the dog races
the dogs chasing the mechanical rabbit
the mechanical rabbit in this case is
the word count and so you chase the word
count you build up the word count which
forces you like the dog who's running it
forces you to read it forces you to
listen you're building up your word
count and all of a sudden you start to
become familiar with the language and
then you can go back in and check up a
few things that relate to grammar and
then when you have some words then you
feel more comfortable comfortable in
engaging people in conversation
but you don't have to do it right away
what you have to do right away is you
have to
single-mindedly pursue words and i can
think of no more efficient way of doing
that than creating
lots of lots of links at link so there
you have it that's the secret of how i
learn languages so some people are going
to say well he learned all of his
languages before like that's true link
is simply a more efficient way
of doing what i have always done
to learn languages
thanks for listening bye